[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 9 janvier 80 km heure
au lieu de 90 la vitesse sur les routes
hors agglomération va pisser le but
endiguer la mortalité dans cette édition
reportage auprès des automobilistes
yvelinois qui nous livrent leurs
réactions
[Musique]
la 76e course au soleil voit l'aube le
parcours du paris nice 2018 a été
dévoilée ce matin à versailles à la
compétition cycliste s'élancera pour la
neuvième fois consécutive des yvelines
et départ le 4 mars de kuyssche à tout
entretien / avec le directeur de la
course françois lemarchand et puis les
soldes d'hiver débutent demain pour six
semaines nous avons suivi la préparation
au centre commercial parly 2 c'est aussi
une période des pièges sont à éviter on
en parle avec philippe le ray est
président du ufc que choisir région de
versailles c'est une première depuis
1974 la vitesse sur les routes hors
agglomération havas a baissé en france
elle passera de 90 à 80 km/heure sur les
axes secondaires sans à terre plein
central
objectif inverser la hausse du nombre de
morts sur les routes cette réduction de
la vitesse sera effective dans quelques
mois et mais alors qu'en pense notamment
les automobilistes yvelinois éléments de
réponse avec patrick jacques de dixmude
et nicolas kirilow liszt de toutes les
mesures annoncées par le gouvernement
c'est elle qui fait le plus parler
réduire la vitesse de 90 à 80 km/heure
permettra-t-il de baisser le nombre de
morts sur les routes au niveau de la
nationale 10 près de trappes les
conducteurs sont divisés sur la question
c'est pas normal parce que on est livré
à ventre après par exemple plus vite on
va le voir et pas après pour les
accidents c'est pas mal mais bon
sinon c'est vrai que bientôt on va
rouler à 60 sur l'autoroute aussi moi je
trouve ça trop lent déjà 90 c'est dur
alors 80 ça va être encore plus dur et
laura moye d'accès dans la digue km ça
m'étonnerait pour le gouvernement cette
mesure qui sera appliquée sur près de
400 mille kilomètres de réseau routier
permettra de sauver jusqu'à 400 vies par
an des chiffres réfutés par certaines
associations d'automobilistes pour l
exécutif se tromper de cible et
chercherait avant tout à faire un coup
politique
vous êtes contrôlés tous les jours
pratiquement et d'aigreur est ce que
vous a été contrôlé récemment avec votre
taux d'alcoolémie c'est extrêmement rare
voyez donc ya pas que ça il ya aussi la
distraction au volant il ya la
somnolence les routes c'est que dans 47
% des accidents
il ya un facteur routier qui est
appliqué en 2012 nous agace qualité de
la route
2012 est champion du monde pour notre
réseau routier en 2007 on est à la
septième place on s'assume complètement
dégradée dans le département des
yvelines plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres pourrait être soumis à cet
abaissement à partir du 1er juillet le
plan du gouvernement prévoit également
un renforcement important des sanctions
pour l'utilisation des téléphones
portables au volant actualité automobile
encore ps a convoqué aujourd'hui à les
syndicats sur son site de poissy est
début des négociations à propos des
ruptures conventionnelles collective que
le groupe soit utilisé à des faits
vrillé la nouvelle disposition à des
ordonnances travail la mesure permet la
suppression de postes sans passer par un
plan social classique
inacceptable pour la cgt psa le syndicat
dénonce dans un communiqué un plan
social déguisé
ils réclament des embauches massives en
cdi psa entend supprimer à 2200 emplois
dont 1300 en rupture conventionnelle
collective et 1300 embauches sont
prévues en parallèle
après les fêtes de fin d'année il faut
penser à se séparer de son sapin mais
pas n'importe comment
à saint quentin en yvelines depuis
plusieurs années et mis en place une
opération de collecte
que vont devenir la ces sapins aurélie
rose a suivi leur parcours à guyancourt
après quelques semaines de gloire il est
temps pour les sapins de retirer leurs
tenues de fêtes
leur place est désormais sur les
trottoirs
durant le mois de janvier dans les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
ils seront ramassés pour être recyclés
c'est la société sepur basée à thiverval
grignon qui est chargé de collecter et
de valoriser ces sapins on va les broyer
et puis une fois qu'ils seront broyés on
va pouvoir les valoriser principalement
en biomasse puisque effectivement c'est
quand même très ligne comme matière et
avec cette biomasse
on va renvoyer sa dans des chaudières
qui vont permettre de créer soit de la
chaleur soit l'électricité
les aiguilles des sapins elles seront
broyés elles deviendront ensuite du
compost destinées à fertiliser les sols
une opération écologique à condition de
respecter quelques consignes ce sac là
et il est fait les spécifique pour le
compostage il va dégrader en même temps
que le process de compostage donc ils
souhaitent faire un prénom
ce qui est gênant se sont tous qui est
guirlandes boules de noël où là je ne
sais pas faire du compost avec donc
sharon toujours tendance à dire on en
irlande les gens m cette année entre 100
et 200 tonnes soir un millier de sapins
qui ont fait le bonheur des saint
quentinois connaîtront une deuxième vie
on reste à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
magny les hameaux a été la première
commune de l'agglomération a donné ses
voeux aux habitants cérémonie hier à la
maison de l'environnement en présence de
plusieurs élus du territoire est la
soirée a débuté par un concert des
enfants manie quoi dans son discours le
maire bertrand au lion est revenu sur
les principales réalisations de 2010 est
très sélectif dans les écoles
accessibilité des équipements publics et
installation d'une chaudière biomasse
il a également précisé les grands
projets pour cette année propos
recueillis par kelly lambert aujourd'hui
par exemple plus rien n'arrête le projet
de circulation de ce qui doit relier
magny les hameaux aux autres communes de
l'agglomération puisque le département a
maintenant pris ses responsabilités
c'est une circulation douce qui doit
relier l'ensemble des hameaux de magny
les hameaux
aujourd'hui la circulation douce par du
quartier du buisson jusqu'à aux hameaux
de villeneuve et il manque un barreau le
long de la route départementale qui est
la responsable du département pour
rejoindre ensuite même village est enfin
passé dans l'ensemble des amours
circulation du site
des travaux qui devraient bientôt a
débuté du sport avec la course au soleil
qui se dévoile le tracé du 76e paris
nice a été présenté ce matin à l'hôtel
du département à versailles est la
compétition de cyclisme partira de
chatou le 4 mars et passera notamment
par la vallée de chevreuse le lendemain
les coureurs s'élanceront depuis la
petite commune yvelinoise d'or sont
ville
patrick jacques de dixmude et michael et
demi d'euros ont rencontré le directeur
de paris nice
entretien la conférence de presse de la
76e édition du paris-nice vient tout
juste de se terminer ici à versailles
pour la neuvième année consécutive les
yvelines seront représentés pour nous
parler à du tracé je suis avec françois
lemarchand le directeur de course de
paris nice françois lemarchand est ce
que c'est un bonheur de partir à chaque
fois des yvelines mais c'est un bonheur
parce que savez je suis un ancien
coureur cycliste mes routes
d'entraînement c'était dans les yvelines
elles le sont toujours mais c'est plus
de l'entraînement c'est de la pratique
dominicale
donc oui sur une terre de vélo sur des
difficultés que l'on trouve un petit peu
partout et dont les gens dont les gens
se souviennent à quand on parle de la
vallée de chevreuse ça parle à tout le
monde donc quand on peut tracer des
parcours dans la vallée de chevreuse et
dans le département des yvelines
c'est fabuleux contre on fait un métier
comme le mien est ce que vous pouvez
vous parler de cette première étape qui
se déroulera le dimanche la première
étape elle partira de château un départ
fictif jusqu'à saint germain en laye et
à la sortie de saint germain en laye un
départ réel pour aller sur sur
villepreux sur ben sur les mais nul et
on va les chercher toutes et toutes les
côtes qui sont qui sont qui sont dans
les yvelines dont certains
connaissent notamment la côte de l'es17
tournant on va les chercher à coups de
boules et les trous on va aller chercher
la coupe de châteaufort mais côté stèle
jacques anquetil donc ça parle aussi ses
démons c'était sont des endroits qui
parle et un retour sur saint quentin en
yvelines
bois d'arcy et après on sûr du
département à la celle saint cloud ça
sera une première étape compliquée ce
serait une première étape compliquée
parce que enfin compliqué j'espère aussi
compliquée que celle que l'on a vécu
cette année à bois d'arcy fin l'an passé
à bois d'arcy puisque ça a été l'une des
plus belles étapes de démission de paris
nice avec le vent la pluie et découvrir
un petit peu partout là on a fait en
sorte de bad met pas mal de portions à
découvert de n'être pas mal de
difficultés donc on espère avoir avoir
avoir un aussi beau spectacle cette
année
enfin que l'an passé décidément est ce
que vous êtes inspiré du parcours
justement de l'année dernière de bois
d'arcy qui a si bien fonctionné pour
dessiner le parcours de 2018 sur cette
première étape inspiré
oui et non parce que
déjà on le fait à l'envers par rapport à
l'année dernière et puis aller chercher
les difficultés on sait on sait où sont
les difficultés
donc on les propose malgré tout et
mais le gros problème c'est les coureurs
qui décident de faire la course pas si
vous avez un temps magnifique que peu de
vent va vous aurez une arrivée au sprint
le cas de bois d'arcy c'est
tout le contraire avant avant avant
excécrable à un temps exécrable et une
superbe course donc après nous on
propose des belles choses appréciant les
causeries dispose d'une deuxième étape
d'or sont ville et un village de 400
habitants
c'est un choix un vrai choix oui parce
que le paris nice doit aller partout
doit partir de n'importe quel village on
sait que les grands stades sont dans les
temps dans les grandes villes
le stade 2 le stade de paris nice il
peut se déplacer un est toute petite
ville 400 habitants c'est c'est une
petite commune mais c'est nécessaire à
notre fonctionnement d'aller d'aller un
peu partout et donc ça va faire drôle
d'avoir la caravane de paris nice qui
sera qui sera au départ d'une si petite
ville on va doubler la population
peut-être pas la tripe et moment-là
doublé et
et donc c'est bien ça on parle du sud du
département tout de suite on va on va
aller dans la bosse donc encore une fois
on espère entier du vent qui est du vent
qui souffle d'ouest pour va pour avoir
du spectable c'est désolant si je dis ça
avec les coureurs pour les coureurs mais
mais quelque part nous organisateurs
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on recherche
aussi où ce sera la première fois que ce
cette étape partira dans son île
première fois oui première fois d'or
sont ville ou par souvent le lundi matin
ce sont souvent des villes étapes
inédites
on est parti de condé sur vègre c'était
c'était la première fois aussi donc on
essaye on essaye de d'aller dans le
département dont confond travaille aussi
avec le conseil départemental des
yvelines pour pour nous d'aider dans ses
choix et dans et dans ses projets mais
nous dès l'instant où on peut
s'installer ou
au niveau de la sécurité pour les
coureurs au niveau route si tour
correspond bien ils représentent que
conseille pas donc on compte en disant
qu on y va bien la question qu'est ce
que vous espérez pour ce paris nice 2018
j'espère qu'on aura du soleil
du soleil du soleil pour la course au
soleil pour la course au soleil et puis
qu'on aura qu'on aura maintenant qu'on
aura une belle course et que les gens
répondent présents également sur le bord
de la route
on a senti une nette amélioration ces
dernières années avec avec beaucoup de
public au départ ou ou sur les zones
arrivé au départ parce qu'on a changé
notre notre façon de travailler avec le
podium signature et la présentation des
coureurs avec avec la télévision est
également sur place pour valoriser
encore une fois le territoire et les
gens les gens lorsqu'ils viennent voir
les coureurs et bien ils peuvent toucher
les coureurs et donc ça c'est ça c'est
parfait donc une réussite à tous les
niveaux d'audience télé mais aussi sur
le bord de la route parce que quand il
ya le public ça veut dire que la course
est attrayante et qu'on a on a gagné une
partie du pari merci françois lemarchand
et bon courage pour l'organisation de ce
paris nice 2018 si beaucoup un entretien
réalisé par michael et demi d'euros
patrick jacques de dixmude aux moyens
techniques qui on rappelle que le grand
départ de ce paris nice ce sera le 4
mars depuis chat tout autre top départ
ça c'est dès demain les soldes d'hiver
commencent pour six semaines d'opération
c'est jusqu'au 20 février et à j - du
début des soldes les enseignes se
prépare à parler d'eux c'est une
première pour les boutiques de la
nouvelle extension inauguré fin novembre
reportage de camille lambert le tour des
boutiques si je vais sur quelque chose
pourquoi pas mais je pense qu'il y aura
plein de budget spécial n'ont pour
l'instant aucun budget je viens la
découverte justement de par l'idh
pas de budget précis mais une curiosité
pour ce nouvel espace de parly 2
inauguré fin novembre 16 nouvelles
boutiques se préparent pour leurs
premières soldes d'hiver cette marque de
bijoux a fêté sa première ouverture en
centre commercial
alors c'est vrai qu'on attend beaucoup
de monde donc on a préparé une liste
affaires importantes en fait de bijoux
en termes de fourchette de prix et on a
renforcé nos effectifs on a prévu quatre
personnes demain sachant qu'en
habituellement on a deux trois personnes
dont on a prévu 4 et peut-être une
cinquième personne en renfort si besoin
en face même constat pour cette enseigne
née sur internet
donc là toutes les équipes sont affairés
à préparer donc ce qu'on nous avons reçu
en termes de matériel pour les soldes
nous avons une équipe assez complète sur
la région la boutique de paris donc pas
de renfort en effectifs en revanche par
contre nous avons des plages horaires un
peu plus large ouverture donc les
équipes seront présents un peu plus
souvent est un peu de renfort également
de la part de nos stagiaires du siège
qui viennent donner un coup de main pour
la préparation des soldes le responsable
mis sur une augmentation de 30 à 50% des
ventes à cette période
un objectif que s'est également fixé le
centre commercial
demain mercredi 10 janvier nous espérons
accueillir quarante cinq mille visiteurs
c'est 40 % de plus qu'à 1 mercredi
habituel et nous avons écrit un objectif
de plus 15% par rapport aux mêmes
mercredi des soldes de l'année dernière
mercredi des soldes 2010 est selon
l'ifop les français ont prévu de
dépenser en moyenne 195 euros un budget
quasi équivalent à celui de l'hiver
dernier et pour parler de ces soldes
d'hiver avec moi en plateau justement
philippe fleuret bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le président du ufc que choisir
région de versailles c'est l'antenne
locale de la célèbre association de
consommateurs les soldes d'hiver comme
celle d'été j'imagine c'est une période
de grande vigilance pour pour vos
bénévoles
oui bien sûr que cette grande vigilance
parce que c'est une période où les
consommateurs achètent davantage et il
ya parfois des possibilités de fraude ou
de déception on va dire de la part des
consommateurs donc on est vigilant des
pièges à éviter qu'on va voir dans un
instant
ensemble les consommateurs auraient qui
pour éviter d'être abusé sur la période
doivent être informés notamment sur la
période les soldes se déroule sur une
période très précises s'est fixé par la
loi oui si ce même depuis 2015
maintenant six semaines avant ces cinq
semaines ou un 6 semaines donc là comme
vous l'avez dit dans le reportage ça
commence le 10 janvier et donc jusqu'au
20 février
avant on parlait de soldes flottants ses
gardes et les soldats qui étaient on va
dire étendu une période complémentaire
pour les soldes aujourd'hui ça c'est
plus possible ça s'est terminé de
toujours depuis 2015 auparavant
effectivement les commerçants ça très
commerçant avec la possibilité de
décider des soldes flottantes sur des
périodes variables selon le moment de
l'année et ça ça a été supprimée
notamment en raison de l'existence des
promos d'accord qui ont lieu tout au
long de l'année donc il y avait une
grande difficulté pour le consommateur
de s'y retrouver donc maintenant c'est
plus simple deux périodes de soldes
soldes les soldes d'hiver janvier
février les soldes d'été
fin juin juillet on est dans un contexte
où le numérique ne cesse de progresser
sur internet sur les applications
mobiles c'est les même période s'est
passé exactement la même chose ça cette
différence c'est que lorsque l'on achète
pendant les soldes sur internet et il ya
possibilité de bénéficier de la
rétractation cr2 encore renoncé à
l'achat de quatorze jours à la suite de
l'achat ce qui est pas possible
généralement riche et bien ça en général
c'est dès réception de la chasse et ça
dès réception de charlie donc on a
quatorze jours 14 à jour sur le désir de
se rétracter
quels sont les produits qui peuvent être
soldés essentiellement c'est dans
l'habillement c'est la vie durant
l'électroménager bon d'autres produits
c'est possible aussi mais pour
l'essentiel ce sont ces produits-là en
sachant que les commerçants n'ont pas le
droit d'acheter des stocks précisément
pour pour les sols ni d'ailleurs de
réapprovisionner leurs stocks au moment
où voilà donc à l'origine reste les
soldes d'hiver que cette date de
boucicaut le gros marché
les soldes ça consistait pour les
commerçants à déstocker sedira à vendre
c
c'est pour les produits qui ne les a
vendues dont leïla à prix réduits voire
en dessous du prix mam est alors que est
donc ce qui était une bonne une bonne
affaire pour le consommateur
voilà donc c'est une relation gagnant
gagnant on va dire alors pendant cette
période on imagine aussi que l'affichage
l'étiquetage doit être également très
clair l'affichage extérieur qui signale
que la boutique fait bien les sols mais
aussi l'étiquetage les des produits des
références il doit être très clair pour
le consommateur oui parce que il ne suis
qu'un doute dessus oui parce qu'il ne
suffit pas de il ya un produit avec une
étiquette -30% -50%
tout ça se fait par rapport à ce qu'on
appelle le prix de référence est donc
c'est ça qui est très important c'est à
dire que la réduction elle se fait par
rapport à un prix fixé par les
commerçants c'est très important c'est
le commerçant qui fixe le prix de base
on va dire le prix de référence à partir
duquel la réduction aura lieu il le fixe
et il a le droit de le bouger avant les
avant les soldes ce prix là le droit de
l'augmenter non non non non non il est
fixé au départ
et justement alors donc sur l'étiquette
voulait dit le prix de référence
j'imagine le prix final le prix de
réduction il faut le pourcentage de
réduction c'est ça oui tu dois être qui
doit être affichée on va pas incriminer
bien sûr les commerçants la plupart la
grande majorité sont sont honnêtes il ya
cependant quelques pratiques malhonnêtes
des stratagèmes malhonnête
pendant les soldes quelles sont vraiment
les pièges à éviter qu'elles quel type
de comportement malhonnête il faut sur
lesquels il faut être vigilant
précisément
c'est sur le prix de référence parce que
donc les un article qui est soldé doit
avoir déjà été mis en vente au moins un
mois avant la date de départ des soldes
l'accord un temps qu'il l'a donc en
l'occurrence il devait avant tout au
long du mois de décembre au minimum
voilà ça c'est la première chose
le prix donc c'est le prix d'avant le
prix de référence sur des prises avant
mais effectivement il faut pas que le
commerçant en profite cirque il est
majoré le prix avant les avant les
soldes c'est au mois de décembre par
exemple ou en novembre décembre
parce que si le prix majoré et à ce
moment-là ça fausse tout comprenez et il
y aussi alors une autre pratique que
j'ai pu voir en documentant c'est des
produits qui de moindre qualité qui sont
produits exclusivement pour les soldes
oui ça s'appellerait c'est peut-être
plus on retrouve on sera peut-être plus
facilement sur internet et peut-être
plus de chances de rester sur internet
généralement chez les deux autres
commerçants ont normalement non c'est
assez rare et puis c'est difficile à
prouver
cette affaire et du coup quand on arrive
en boutique elle réflexes à adopter pour
éviter les balles sont les fausses
bonnes affaires
alors quand on arrive en boutique déjà
bon s'assurer que je conversais revenir
des soldes vérifiez aussi quels articles
sont soldées parce que charmant il ya
des des pastilles rouges des pastilles
vertes avec des différents barèmes donc
bien bien repérer tout cela ça serait
aussi que le commerçant reprend ou
échange le programme ça doit être aussi
indiqué que le aussi produit n'est ni
échangés ni remboursés ça doit être
précisé oui parce que le commerçant n'a
pas l'obligation de le faire d'accord
général le font tous un mets donc ça il
fait savoir où il va rembourser ou
ou échanger parler toutes ces violences
elles sont adoptées aussi pour les
achats sur internet c'est la même chose
pour la dernière question que je vais
vous poser
si on suit tous vos précieux conseils
bien sûr on n'est pas à l'abri de se
faire quand même piéger
quels sont les moyens dont on dispose si
on veut se retourner le problème de deux
possibilités donc s'adressait à l'ufc
que choisir donc à l'association de
versailles pour les habitants des
yvelines
et puis également donc un cas de
contrefaçon par exemple de problèmes sur
la qualité de produit ou de la qualité
socialement donc ça c'est à la ddpp à la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations qui t'a
services de la préfecture qui se trouve
à versailles et rue mermoz est ce que
vous l'avez précisé ufc que choisir est
là aussi donc pour conseiller les
consommateurs elle est là aussi pour
traiter les litiges de ses adhérents oui
absolument c'est à dire que si une
personne se steam dès et elle vient nous
rencontrer et à ce moment là donc on va
l'aider à obtenir satisfaction germain
il s'agit de récupérer un g10 financiers
et donc je peux vous dire c'est qu'on
traite environ 650 litige par an et en
la région de versailles précisément une
grand et on a récupéré environ 200000
euros donc parents qu'aux restituer
intégralement aux anneaux à dire tous
ces litiges tous ces exemples finalement
ça vous aide aussi à peut-être vous
enrichir sur sur certains points
constituer des dossiers pour les soldes
d'après ça vous permet d'être mieux
documenter mieux ce rallye par une
association née bruit et vincent richer
en tout cas et donc pour vous contacter
un je précise qu'on peut se rendre sur
le site internet qui va s'afficher qui
s'affiche actuellement en bas de l'écran
merci à philippe le ray d'avoir ainsi
avec du président du ufc que choisir
région de versailles et je rappelle que
le le site internet sa fille si vous
souhaitez contacter les bénévoles de
l'association et obtenir aussi d'autres
informations sur d'autres thématiques
que les soldes c'est une nouvelle
structure d'accueil des jeunes familles
à maurepas depuis hier plusieurs
établissements de la petite enfance se
retrouvent sur un même lyon centre ville
l'escale l'équipement
semble une halte jeux de 20 berceaux une
microcrèche un relais assistants
maternels et un espace parents enfants
ouvert les lundi matins
une remise à neuf des locaux a été
nécessaire des travaux débutés en août
montant estimé 212 mille euros dont 70
mille euros de subventions et puis avant
de se quitter c'est votre rendez vous à
chaque mardi dans le 7-8 journal le
portrait de la rédaction est consacrée
aujourd'hui à des luthiers les d'amico
il fabrique réparer ce tort des
instruments de musique le couple
travaille les guitares depuis 1995 et
leur boutique est située à bitche dans
les yvelines
rencontre avec mélanie poker et nicolas
danos y fit donc on a régulièrement
l'atelier des petits boulots à peu près
4 à 5 par mois
cd tête fracturée cole ponçage et vernis
depuis 20 ans grégoire d'amico soit
nouveau guitar passionné de musique il
devient luthier en 1995 dans un sous-sol
de pavillons il crée lui même les
instruments
montre en fin de compte un manche de
guitare briques
voilà donc à la base on voit que c'est
une planche
voilà on réalise avec la dégommer
raboteuse on vient faire des collages ce
qui va permettre de mettre des boîtes
différents dans le dans le manche
d'insérer des bois différents et ça
permet au bois de moins bouger avec les
poèmes d'hydrométrie et des guitares sur
mesure parfois très haut de gamme pour
des grands de la musique française et
internationale
charlet des coudes sur francis cabrel
laurent voulzy ou encore mick jagger
alors voilà ce dont je t'avais parler
1la la corde obame est donc celle ci tu
vois là sa particularité c'est d'être
complètement en palissandre donc là tu
vas avoir un son un petit peu plus
encore pu médium voilà voilà entre les
deux duc l'accord mais pas mal de médium
elle le sous sol devient très vite trop
petit tout comme l'atelier dans le
hameau de villars où à guyancourt
il déménage à buc et ouvre une boutique
et c'est surtout de faire un lieu où les
gens se sentent bien voilà ouais ils se
sentent à l'aise pour essayer leurs
instruments avec une âme avec avec avec
on va dire une un peu de charme qui soit
pas un lieu édulcorer un peu insipide
parce que souvent les magasins on va
dire il n'ya pas y'a pas vraiment
d'imaginaire voilà et nous on a mis un
peu nos tripes
ok ben je vais essayer
a fait une adresse qui fonctionne grâce
au bouche à oreille
les clients sont des fidèles ici je vous
sais vraiment
un endroit extraordinaire il déjà il ya
beaucoup de choix de deux guitares et
puis il a un savoir faire
pour ce qui est de le réglage l'an
l'occurrence c'était pour une casse
malheureusement c'est une guitare auquel
je tiens énormément que j'ai depuis que
je suis gamin puis j'ai 17 ans j'en ai
30 37 bientôt et je voulais vraiment pas
[Musique]
voilà les vrais mots qui ne leur fasse
plus de vingt ans de savoir-faire et 700
produits en boutique avec toujours à la
fin le petit mot de circonstance je
viens salut salut bonne musique
voilà c'est la fin de 68 journal merci
de l'avoir suivi ripley et reportages a
consultés sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]